en las elecciones estatales de este
domingo en las que se renovaron seis
gubernaturas
de acuerdo con los resultados de los
conteos rápidos organizados por una
autoridad electoral morena el partido
del presidente de lópez obrador se alzó
con el triunfo en cuatro estados donde
era oposición se trata de hidalgo oaxaca
tamaulipas y quintana roo con ello de
concretarse este resultado con los
cómputos distritales
morena y sus aliados estarían gobernando
21 entidades de las 32 que hay en el
país
motivo por el cual el líder del partido
mario delgado se dijo muy contento de
haber demostrado que la cuarta
transformación como denominan a su
proyecto a su movimiento está dando
resultados y avanza rumbo al 2024 en
contraste la alianza opositora
conformada por los partidos pan pri y pr
de retuvieron las gubernaturas de
aguascalientes y durango el dirigente
del pan así como el del pri se dijeron
satisfechos de haber demostrado que pese
a lo que consideraron una operación de
estado para coaccionar y comprar el voto
estados ellos mostraron que su coalición
opositora es viable y será un reto para
el partido del gobierno para el 2024
cuando se renueve la presidencia de la
república se trató de una jornada
electoral que transcurrió en
tranquilidad sin incidentes mayores pero
en la que la participación ciudadana
ciertamente fue más baja que en el
anterior proceso electoral